well ladies and gentlemen the gloves
have come off an illegal war between
Turner Tenny aka T foo and faze clan has
just been turned up one big [ __ ]
notch
faze clan has countersued T foo let's
get into it
so where do we start well how about a
quick and dirty road map to exactly what
faze clan is accusing tegu of in this
lawsuit then we'll get into the details
a bit more and explore a few more of the
interesting points of this new lawsuit
first of all faze clan wants some brand
deal money that they say they'd never
collected on and they claim T foo is
withholding they claim he entered into
third-party agreements without their
consent they claim he's divulged
confidential information that he
shouldn't have that he's publicly
slandered the company that he's stolen
and misused trade secrets that he's
trying to get other faze clan members to
jump ship with him and finally that T
foo made Bank off faze clan and they
want some of that back oh okay
so if faze clan is successful in suing
for some or all of the above they are
seeking big financial compensation and
an injunction preventing t foo from
divulging any trade secrets or
confidential information for 3 years
after his contract expires and it still
hasn't by the way they're also seeking
an injunction that would prevent T foo
from essentially bad-mouthing faze clan
till the end of time now this lawsuit
starts off with a banger of an
allegation saying that T foo quote
betrayed faze clan and his teammates he
has caused them serious damage and
stands to do more and quote right off
the bat the entire blanka's of this
lawsuit really wants to communicate the
idea that faze clan made TV that while
he is and always was an exceptionally
skilled gamer it was faze clan that came
along and taught him how to monetize
that taught him how to make it into a
successful business
in the lawsuits own words faze clan
quote schooled
teni in the business social media and
gaming practices that have made faze
clan successful end quote
the lawsuit tries to back this claim by
showing the number
of T through social media followings and
his growing sub count for YouTube and
twitch after he was signed to faze clan
in April of 2018 and this idea is really
the backbone of the lawsuit the idea
that hey you're a good game or T foo but
you wouldn't be anywhere near what you
are today without us the lawsuit claims
that faze clan knows the secrets of
creating and marketing content and
creating personalities for their brand
it mentions quote groundbreaking methods
and techniques for enhancing and in some
cases creating the popularity of gaming
related media personalities and
professionalizing their approach end
quote
the lawsuit also talks about secret
knowledge or at least confidential
information on faze clans business
partners practices their future business
plans their contracts etc and if this
information in part that they are
accusing T foo of stealing and misusing
the lawsuit alleges that T foo wants to
take all this information all of these
secrets and start a rival org they
accuse him of directly or indirectly
trying to get current faze clan members
or current faze clan business partners
to jump ship and come over to T foo they
specifically mentioned cloak C here and
if you've been following this story line
for the last several weeks you know that
he is in a now very public to speak with
faze clan and on the way out the lawsuit
accuses Teague of using the faze clan
name and brand to leverage third party
sponsorship or endorsement deals off of
which he made according to the lawsuit
about twenty million dollars and almost
none of which again according to the
lawsuit he shared with face the lawsuit
text actually claims he quote secretive
way the money it goes on to say that T
foo has quote unilaterally retained all
but sixty thousand dollars consequently
Tenny owes faze clan the remaining
portion of the revenues received by
Tenny under the gamer agreement and
quote basically what the lawsuit is
saying here is that faze clan are taking
the [ __ ] gloves off and they want
their money they want that old 80/20
split this is a bit weird though because
in all prior official faze clan
communications they claimed that they
chose not to exercise the right to the
monies owed to them via brain
deels whether it's an 80/20 split a 2080
split or a 50/50 split except of course
for the afro mentioned $60,000 in fact
faze clan CEO lead shrink even once said
quote the relationship with T foo was
more important than money
end quote I guess that's changed before
they're saying that they chose not to
collect now they're saying that he's
withholding money due now for those of
you who've been following this case
since the beginning the 80/20 split
should be very familiar to you we
haven't talked about it in a while
because it was one of the initial
controversies of the P food vs. faze
clan lawsuit now it was seemingly
universally agreed upon that Tebow's
original gamer agreement was not
appropriate at all for what he was
bringing to faze clan and we do know
that that agreement was renegotiated or
at least attempts to renegotiate it were
made many times throughout last year and
early this year with faze clan going
back to t foo and presenting him with
different iterations of the contract
that were better and better and better
and T foo refusing according to faze
clan to sign them for faze clans side
they say that that's because T food
never wanted a better contract that what
he wanted was just to be out of one now
T Fu's lawyer told me in a previous
video that it was because those
contracts all iterations including the
original gamer agreement were illegal in
a number of ways
faithlyn was presented with the contract
Turner would accept it was you know as
close to a legal contract and you can
get but apparently that wasn't good
enough for them and they decided to mark
up about half of it get rid of about
half of it put in their own provisions
which again made it illegal once again
for more details on exactly what that
means please check out a previous
coverage now faze clan seems more than a
little upset at T Foos perceived
unwillingness to negotiate any contracts
and the following line in this latest
lawsuit really encapsulates that quote
it turns out Teddy wanted nothing less
than to tear up the agreement he made
with faze clan so he could take all he
had learned from faze clan and all that
faze clan had helped to build and keep
everything for himself
end quote now a quick note about where
this lawsuit was filed the Southern
District Court of New York to be exact
that is the
the location in which the original gamer
agreement stipulated that any legal
action pertaining to that agreement had
to take place if you watched our
previous coverage on this issue you know
that T Fu's lawsuit was filed in the
state of California and according to his
lawyer that is the appropriate venue
because that is where faze clans
business is located this lawsuit however
contends that New York is a neutral
court and notes that it specifically
permits non-residents to choose New York
jurisdiction now according to this
lawsuit faze clan is also concurrently
filing a motion to dismiss t Fu's
California lawsuit for allegedly not
being filed in the right venue ok so
this is the umpteenth time that I've
appeared here on the score eSports to
explain a lawsuit that involves faze
clan and T foo so where we add at this
point well T foo has sued faze clan in
the state of California alleging that
his contract is illegal and should be
null and void that court case is still
ongoing Bay's claim for their part have
sued T foo in the state of New York
saying that no the contract wasn't
illegal and in fact you've broken it in
a number of different ways so we want to
be compensated for that
at the same time faze clan has also
filed to dismiss that means quash or get
rid of the California lawsuit that t foo
filed as of the recording of this video
all of these lawsuits are ongoing and
none of them have reached a conclusion
they could be settled out of court every
single one of them or it's unlikely but
each one could go to court in which case
we'd be looking at years of prolonged
legal battles possibly thanks for
watching if you want more content like
this hit the sub button and bring that
notification bell for unique bite-sized
videos you won't find anywhere else hit
up our Instagram Twitter and Facebook
pages
[Music]
you
[Music]